this is a production of Cornell
University
and I wanted to start
and particularly agricultural
are often will indicate that plows are
one of the markers of of a civilized
agriculture in more developed
agriculture this first is a quote from
Kurt who is that an American
agricultural historian and you said you
see here is quote through the ages the
plow has been the most important
agricultural tool indeed without it
farmers could not tell the soil and
prepare their fields for extension of
Agriculture but even more closer to home
our own liberty hi Bailey said at
tillage is so universal and so obviously
essential it's a successful agriculture
that we accept it without questioning
its origin yet among modern farmers
tillage is rarely practiced with
sufficient frequency to produce the best
results but prior to colonization
farmers in the Western Hemisphere had no
access to Klaus in order to draft
animals and yet they had very both
extensive and intensive agriculture that
was accomplished completely by hand and
I'm showing you three pictures here one
from Machu Picchu of Incan agriculture
on terraces another two from Mayan and
also asked at agriculture again intense
but without clouds the last pitcher in
in the corner the black and white is a
drawing by a Jesuit who was visiting
mohawk country in the 17th century and
this is a picture of a mohawk woman with
a hand tool also probably planted so
what I wanted to do this afternoon we
have a unique opportunity to look at the
effects of tillage in one place over
several hundred years both agriculture
with and without village right here in
kind of western New York but I want to
start out with the Mohawks who were
growing corn over closer to the Hudson
Valley and this is a quote in a journal
by a Dutchman Adrian Cornelison van der
Donck and he was in the Hudson Valley in
1653 and he says he wrote in his report
the women do all the farming and
planting they grow no wheat oats barley
rye etc and are unacquainted with
plowing and spade work and do not keep
their lands tight they know nothing of
maneuvering fallow seasons and proper
tillage the labor they devote is all men
using small adzes nevertheless they
raise so much corn and beans
just these from them and fully loaded
yachts and snooze so there is this
indication of a productive agriculture
taking place here in what is today New
York State that was done completely
without plows and other types of
mechanized or major tillage operations
so I'd like to examine that in more
detail and for those of you who are not
familiar with the Mohawks the Mohawks
were one of the original five nations of
the Iroquois Confederacy and the map on
the on the right shows you what those
territories look like about 1650 and the
map on the left shows that your coy
Iroquois and language speakers the kind
of dark purple Iroquois Confederacy is
with no them what part of a larger group
of Native peoples who spoke similar
language Club your plan languages and
this is what it might have looked like
before your transverse beam so you see
people are similar language the dark
purple inhabiting for residing in a
fairly large portion of of the
northeastern in all of New York
so I talked about the mall Fox and the
Mohawks were where we saw the first
quote of about how their agriculture was
productive even though they knew nothing
of plows and renewals or fallows or
anything else but we're going to move
west over into King good and also Seneca
tear for this this is a map of Iroquois
settlements that were in existence
sometime between 1352 1730 and what I've
done just for your kind of orientation
is to place if the good Geneva in
Rochester on now the triangles that are
dark our ones that were before 1550 and
the ones that are light colored are
those that were occupied after 1550
agriculture in your community is
intensified sometime about 1450 and
onward and what we see is there was a
kind of concentration of many
settlements alone that kind of east-west
axis let me show you a little bit more
of this if we look at where the York or
settlements were and where most the
agriculture was taking place it's in
this broad area outlined in red here
that happens to contain some of New
York's most agriculturally productive
land if we look at Eric white maize and
how it was managed we know that it was
controlled by women that the crops were
planted without plows there are no
animals that the fields were
continuously cropped and that it was a
highly productive agriculture so you
might say well what evidence do we have
of that productivity well they come from
two areas first historical documents the
book on the right General John
Sullivan's Indian expedition of 1779
contains lots of the Diaries and
journals of officers involved in the
Sullivans campaign which came up in two
key you good and Seneca territories we
also have available some contemporary
field experiments then that I've done
that have looked at what crop yields
might have been the let's look first at
these historical documents and they come
from two primary areas both of them as a
result of European attacks particularly
on Seneca territories invoke the
seventeenth and eighteenth centuries and
both of these these incidents these two
historical incidents about a hundred
years apart provide us a lot of
information on maize productivity the
first one is denied though the guy up
there 1687 a Frenchman he goes into a
kid noggin that's the one in blue there
that's located to come if you've been to
the again and again historical side view
in western New York in Victor New York
it's just south of rochester this was
one of the major Iroquois major actually
Seneca settlement said at that time and
then Sullivan a hundred years later went
all around you
seneca lake and but more specifically
over into the western part of new york
through canandaigua and one of the major
areas called genesis castle let's first
look at the nine belt and this is a map
that was made after his his time and it
actually has solvents campaign on it as
well but he came down from Lake Ontario
through this area what today is is
rochester and then he began marching on
hurdle a large army down into seneca of
territories and the reason for doing
this was that the the seneca were
collaborating and aligned themselves
with Great Britain and France and Great
Britain were at war over who was going
to control in North America and denied
aval knew that the Seneca had large
fields of corn they were supplying
British troops with corn so he was
coming down in order to try to destroy
and to to frighten intimidate and reduce
the capacity of the Seneca villages from
providing English soldiers with food and
so good not again was the site of of a
major of greenery storage area was kind
of the heart of Seneca maze agriculture
well the novel reported and letters back
to his superiors in France that over
nine days he and his
destroyed over a million bushel of corn
and that it was both stored corn and
corn that was green in the field and you
can see what he writes fear about it
after having destroyed a vast quantity
of fine large corn beans and other
vegetables of which they remained not a
single field and after having burned so
large quantity of old corn that would be
Stuart point that the amount dare not be
mentioned the quantity of corn which we
found in store in this place and
destroyed by fire is incredible
alright so we have one picture of in a
fairly detailed description of what
agriculture looked like in maître Seneca
areas where they were growing corn about
a hundred years later John Sullivan
comes into almost the exact same area
but he makes a much more extensive trip
through central and in western New York
and he was ordered by by George
Washington who gave him these
instructions in a letter in early 1779
in May of 1779 he writes that the
immediate objectives are the total
destruction and devastation of their
settlements meaning primarily Seneca
onondaga and Cuba it will be essential
to groom their crops in the ground and
prevent their planting more and the
reason for this once again it was that
the majority of the Iroquois four out of
six nations had sided with Great Britain
in the Revolutionary War so once again
they were supplying British soldiers
with corn so Sullivan is is ordered to
go up into this area and destroyed
villages and the crops and these little
guidelines show where where he went
there actually a couple of them came
Clinton came from this direction
Sullivan came farther from farther south
in Pennsylvania they went up this would
be cleared away consent of the lake
first going up along the eastern side of
Seneca going all the way out west to
what is today geneseo coming back down
along the western side of Q the lake and
then I look up along the eastern side
and all of the time burning villages and
more importantly destroying cornfields
well out of this this campaign we have
put Diaries and journals a number of the
officers who participated in this
campaign I've just picked out I think
there's six here 50 that all are from
late August and they were in primarily
areas around geneseo a little to the
east of you know geneseo canandaigua and
a bit farther west and these you know
officers described the corn that that
they saw the agriculture that they saw
and you see that the quotes 150 acres of
the best corn I ever saw in such
quantities would be almost incredible to
a civilized people some corn stalks
measuring 18 feet and a kobs 11 foot and
a half long we found two hundred acres
of exceedingly good corn intermixed with
beans and squashes pop humans and a few
potatoes we distill we destroyed large
fields of their porn they plant with as
much exactly as any farmer so a very
detailed picture of productive and
extensive agriculture these are not
backyard garden cesare large
agricultural fields 100 150 acres 200
acres sometimes there were there there
were there were records or both of these
officers that they went they saw corn
fields that were more than a mile in
length so huge amount of you know
agriculture going on and obviously
indicative of the fairly productive and
high yielding
so that's part of what the information
from historical documents tells us but
we also have some from field experiments
and this is work that I started back in
nineteen ninety-three and carried
through to 1997 we did it at two sites
one right in this area in Cayuga County
at the West great research farm and the
other outside of this very highly
productive area in Hawkins County on a
farm about eight miles east and south of
pisgah today I'm just going to show you
the results from to you go because I
think they are most representative of
what of what Iroquois farmers would have
been able to achieve since they're in
the same area same climate same spoils
so we use the maize variety an open
pollinated white flour corn that is
still grown by by airport people today
from everything that we know it is very
similar to
they're probably in the fifteen sixteen
seventeen and eighteen hundreds so it's
quite similar it's an open pollinated
variety as a much lower yield potential
to do our our modern hybrids and we used
economic practices that were as similar
as we couldn't thank them to what the
Iroquois would have used in the
seventeenth centuries we tried for
populations for spacing we did some some
variations but we tried for things that
we thought would be realistic so these
are from two years in Tioga County and
we had two different populations ten
thousand and twenty thousand plants per
per acre and replanted them at two
different spacings one a 40 inch and a
16 inch and what we found in both years
was that the highest yields not surprise
me came from the narrow spacing in the
high population and so at the very
highest fields we were getting close to
seventy five bushels per acre right and
the very lowest at the 96 at 10,000
plans to know and a wide spacing about
thirty five thirty eight bushels per
acre so we saw that as as there's all
sorts of indications that the year point
planted fairly high populations so my
guess is that you know 40 inches and
twenty thousand plants per acre is
probably realistic and so summers
between
five bushels per acre it is probably a
fairly typical yield so the question
immediately is are these yields realism
is talking about 50 to 75 bushels per
acre you know Iroquois corn how does
this match up with what we know well we
have plenty of records that under good
management open pollinated days in the
United States in the 19th and early or
the 20th century's frequently yielded 75
12 hundred bushels brick but the
important words there are good
management and these were on fields that
were even in fact we had records of 200
bushels per acre in the 19th century in
New York State and owned it but these
are in fields that were either newly
opened meaning they have not been
previously cultivated or they had been
rotated and for received applications of
animal ways
but many people in the field of
particular anthropology would would find
fault with it right if you look in in
the literature of what yields are
purported to be amongst Native Americans
in both generally North America but more
specifically in each group eastern and
central North America their yields are
much much lower what they estimate that
yields to have been and one of the major
person it's been doing this work as an
anthropologist at Wisconsin Schroeder
and she says in I in an article for 1999
that 10 to 15 bushels per acre was
typical and that other people that have
been claiming either you know 25 to 30
bushels per acre or even you know much
about 15 that this was an exaggeration
now al Qaeda rich and trigger our people
are too anthropologists who have studied
the Huron were closely related in
Ontario and their work indicated 15 to
25 bushels per acre of corn was what
they thought would be typical and then
they was working in Tennessee and at
earlier time with Mississippian period
pharmacist would have probably been
around 1300 and he surmised or estimated
that the
range of 12 to 25 bushels per acre so
what is the rationale for these
estimates well all three all four of
these scholars have based their
estimates on yields that u.s. and
Canadian farmers would get when they
grow corn continuously on plowed fields
but without adding fertilizers or any
other source of nitrogen and these
modern farmers when they were questioned
indicated that their corn yields decline
quite steadily after five years or less
of continuous corn without fertilizers
not surprising if you grow corn for five
years and plow every year Atlanta that's
not been manured Orbis each other you
know nitrogen sources yields go down so
they survived from that that native
farmers would have experienced the same
yield reductions forcing them to either
open new lands in what people think of
as typical of North above the entire
western hemisphere shifting cultivation
or to accept declining meals and so I I
would challenge that in interpretation
and I challenge it primarily because
they have neglected the role of organic
matter and villager in soil fertility in
pre-industrial cropping systems plant
nutrients
and I'm here I'm talking exclusively
about nitrogen because I think this is
the team that absolute the controller of
corneas there's three ways that farmers
can can get it animal waste leg use poor
soil organic matter well native farmers
in in the Americas didn't have animal
waste and they didn't have legumes they
didn't have forces to rely on either
they relied exclusively on soil organic
chem and tillage plays a key role in the
ability of soil organic matter to
provide nitrogen so without considering
the role of tillage and soil organic
matter the explanations and the
rationales that is other scholars that
presented don't really stand up and
here's why we know this is a graph from
Brady and while the nature property was
probably if you take it as all this
course you've seen this this shows the
effects of tillage on soil organic
matter and we start at it and on the
left-hand side if that axis is the
amount of soil organic matter in plants
per hectare and the horizontal axis is
increasing time going from 0 up to 130
years right and the soil organic matter
is divided into these different
components first plant residues in the
very bright green then the active Organa
better than slow organic matter and then
what they term the passive organic
matter cool almost all of the nitrogen
that is released upon decomposition of
soil organic matter comes from
everything but the passive organic
matter cool in other words this is
pretty it does great things in terms of
structure and other other things for for
soils but in terms of providing nitrogen
almost nothing all of the nitrogen comes
growth from these areas very fast from
plant residues and very fast from the
active organic matter more slowly under
with the the slope organic matter what
we see is that with time these pools go
down very very quickly and by ten years
we've seen a very steep decline in the
total amount of soil organic matter and
almost all of that loss has been from
the portion that provides nitrogen to
crops notice here we get out to a place
where it it plateaus usually this would
be about 2% soil
at this point the soils ability to
release nitrogen for uptake by plants
has almost bottom down so if we were
looking at yields they would go along
the simplest ain't pretty high up here
to the normal sudden you're going to go
down and then they were parallel this
line so your guilt will will go down you
still get something but your yields will
drop quite strongly notice here organic
matter organic matter management
improved or the land is put back into
native vegetation and this active
sources begin to rebuild and if you
cultivated again when you were over here
you would get an increase in crop yields
so we know that when we fly we initially
increase the soil fertility if you go
into a land that has not previously been
plowed then you will get really nice
yields if the soil organic matter levels
harvest moon pie that's because we get
the oxidation of the soil organic matter
that oxidation releases nitrogen informs
the chem that plants can take up since
nitrogen is usually the most limiting
nutrient for cereal grains yields
increase and plowing fields that have
been valid or pastured and allowed to
accumulate soil organic matter is a
reliable mechanism for providing
nitrogen to props and it's used
worldwide the problem happens when we
continue to plow and cloud and plow and
we get out of this downward curve and we
don't add some other source of nitrogen
or we don't rebuild the soil organic
matter less nitrogen gets released every
year and grain yields inevitably decline
so these soils eventually reach what
about a two percent soil organic matter
in which no further loss happens but
then they're very little nitrogen is
released at that flat file and farmers
will typically call these soils worn out
we know that the single largest cause of
dupree soil organic matter and
agricultural
alright so let's begin to put all of
these pieces together as I mentioned
before the Iroquois were growing their
their maze in this area of central New
York that we know is our most productive
soils one of the reasons that we the
souls are productive is that their alpha
sauce this first map shows all of the
alpha cells in in the United States
don't pay attention to to the different
colors those are just moisture regimes
but notice alphas all's right there in
the center of New York State no surprise
that those are our most agriculturally
productive soils our other large group
and even better soils are model songs
but those are located more towards the
west and in the center part of the
country but notice also that the good
soils in the eastern part of the country
there's not much of them these otha salt
are here in parts of Pennsylvania and a
little smatterings of them down here but
there's not a lot of good agricultural
land on the eastern seaboard Iroquois
were very fortunate to be residing in
that area of really nice soils so
they're growing maize on this highly
productive soils so the question is what
would happen if you look form
continuously on these alpha cells but
without diligent would we expect to see
a decline in crop yields and I would say
it depends on two things first what is
the initial level of the soil organic
matter and second how much corn are you
taking
what are your heels love those are the
things that we control it's very hard to
find information on unplowed alpha salt
with they don't exist right but from
what I can gather a four percent soil
organic matter would be a conservative
estimate of what an uncloudy alpha solve
would contain that would release summers
between 82 160 pounds of nitrogen per
acre per year we know that from
precipitation and decomposition of plant
residues you could probably get another
15 to 30 so this gives us a total
available of somewhere between 100 and
200 pounds if we look at how it's a
nitrogen were taking law 75 bushels per
acre of maize remove somewheres between
75 to 125 pounds of nitrogen per acre
now we know always that we have to have
more nitrogen than what the plant
actually takes up and say no you have to
have more but it's clear that we have
one and a half to two times as much
nitrogen in this system and we could
take off 75 bushels per acre of nitrogen
every year provided that the soil
organic matter level stays at four
percent meaning that the land is not
flat and that there is no need for
additional
in other words that farmers in your
point in 1687 one did not look in down
could have had great high heels and a
hundred years later perhaps even in that
same feel farmers could have still been
getting 50 75 perhaps even a hundred
bushels of corn that is not unreasonable
and the thing that holds it together is
the fact that they're not cloud alright
but things change Iroquois were
dispossessed of their land after the
Revolutionary War in this dispossession
sets up an opportunity for us to look at
to have our own experiment of what
happens when farmers come in and use
plots what happens to corn yields that
particularly if they're using the same
types of open pollinated varieties which
they were right so this is why the map
on the left is what things look like in
1720 about a hundred years later the
Iroquois have been reduced to these
small small territories reservations and
US farmers have flooded into the area
taking over these areas if we look at
this map today the areas of land that
your poor people control would be
probably about twenty five percent of
this even even small so we get this
sweet into what happened Iroquois
country and now becomes
state and in 1799 there was efforts by
land speculators to try to determine
what the agricultural potential of this
area was called and they referred to it
as the Genesee country and so we get
these reports of people visiting this
land who were looking to me to first to
sell it to farmers and they wanted to
know what the agricultural potential of
it was alright so this is a there's a
whole series of what are called letters
from a gentleman to his friend in 1799
and this is a land speculator and he's
telling other speculators kind of what
he thinks the agricultural potential of
this he says the flats of the Genesee
River and the canis croghan Creek alone
cannot be estimated at less than 80
miles in length and about 2 in breast
pouring a body of about 8,000 acres and
every acre is I suppose eight feet deep
of black mold perhaps a bit of an
exaggeration
if you've been out in the Genesee Valley
and looked at some of those soils you
know not much it's pretty nice-looking
soils out there he said in such land the
Indians raise 100 bushels of corn on an
acre and they never have been known to
make any change of the spot in other
words they're continuously profit and
they're getting 100 bushels of corn per
acre others guys trying to sell land
right so there's probably an
exaggeration to it but not a whole lot
more quotes the famous Genesee flats are
about 20 20 miles of length about four
miles wide the soil is remarkably rich
quite clear trees and producing grass
near 10 feet high in places we found
openings of two and three hundred acres
free from all timber and even bushes
which I are examining proved to be of a
rich soil corn generally goes to the
amount of 30 to 40 bushels on an acre
and I'm Flatts up the Genesee River and
of mud creek it is set to the extent of
70 to 80 bushels an acre and is very
heavy and substantial involvement at
this time even 30 to 40 bushels per acre
of what colonial farmers and early
American farmers at the beginning the
typical yields along the eastern
seaboard on those worn-out soils were
lucky often times in 25 bushels to the
acre of corn and usually around 10 to 15
of the week so they were coming from a
perspective of soils in that grade so
let's get worn out we don't expect great
yields here 30 to 40 bushels I'm an
average place and on some of the better
70 to 80 bushels per acre so this last
fall comes from McMahon
who wrote the agricultural history of
the Genesee Valley 1790 day 360 this was
written in in 1952 and and he kind of um
he sums up it provides a picture of what
it looked like the information which
they've heard of the Genesee country
made it appear to land seekers a
veritable agricultural paradise the land
was ready and to the east farmers
pressed by circumstance prepared to move
into new areas these were predominantly
New Englanders who had been trying to
grow crops on Spota cells and had not
been having a great deal of luck after
the first flush of soil organic matter
had been removed they were growing wheat
things were not looking good they were
hungry for new land the Genesee country
looked like the answer to farmers dreams
so this is what happens in 1810 the map
there on your left shows das each dot
represents a hundred in the Genesee
country right and you see by 1860 the
population has just absolutely I don't
know what the total numbers is but it's
multiplied hope you know many many times
the population just increases
dramatically so this is what the area
looks like it includes these these
counties but I'm concentrating mostly at
these upper ones because this is where
the more fertile soils are the elevating
ones are down you're getting into the
southern tier how to straighten sales
but the the northern half of the Genesee
country is where these fertile soils are
so after the entry of the US farmers
with their cloud based agriculture
what happened to measure well there's
very little information from 1800 to
1845 because the early New York
agricultural censuses don't provide
populated they provide production but
you don't know I how and how many acres
so it's almost impossible to get any
sense but by 1845 average room as yields
in the best agricultural lands of
Western New York we're less than thirty
bushels in there so let's look at what
happens from 1845 to 1940 at genesee
Livingston Monroe Ontario and I included
Senegal though that was not in the
original Genesee country but it is one
of our highest producing agricultural
States in certainly place that the year
point were growing their their crops as
well we see that in 1845 the yields are
considerably below 30 bushels per acre
and they kind of stutter along
occasionally growing up a bit but it's
not until as that acting not 20 that we
really get up to even approach
bushes right begin to see some of these
is you know counties now granted these
are averages these are entire county
averages they include good farmers poor
farmers in between farmers so there is
no doubt that there were some farmers
that were getting better gift but the
more important question is what enabled
this increase from 25 up to 250 what was
going on that allowed that to happen so
I didn't have myself first we have to
talk about why did the yields decline
and what everybody would say is soil
depletion and again this is McNall this
is the guy writing the history of the
agricultural history of the Genesee
Valley he says New Englanders remember
those are the folks that were flooding
in your predominantly you little of the
methods or importance of rotating crops
a three crop system rain grass and
fellow did little to maintain soil
fertility soil a millions were
conspicuously neglected animal manures
were not systematically careful use
artificial fertilizers were not employed
says farmers whether telling the rich
soils of the Genesee or elsewhere were
guilty of defective cropping practices
the fertility of there
Seth by repeated profits by poor
rotation schemes or done by the neglect
of fertilizers so how did the yield
increase how did farmers get around this
problem well it's the introduction of
forged legumes saves them same thing
happened in europe with european farmers
it was not until they discovered clover
that cloud agriculture becomes a
sustainable practice in the in the u.s.
it's predominantly clover and later
alfalfa this is combined with the more
careful use of animal manure and this
ameliorates effects of intensive cloud
forge leggings have very different
characteristics than do brain modules so
it's not good enough to just add a beam
we have a picture of a piece here and
over there is elf elf right look at the
difference in those two cops the peas
are in and the amount of organic matter
biomass and nitrogen that they
contribute to the following problem is
mental first because we eat the P and
most of the nitrogen goes with it right
and unless we're returning nightsoil to
the to the land that nitrogen is is lost
second there's hardly any biomass third
that prop dies as soon as it's cut so
once you go through and harvest the the
P
and you cut that plant it's grown it's
it's growing period is over now compare
that with a prof like red clover or
alfalfa number one you're not removing
the grain it's staying at most you may
be fitting into an anime and returning
the waist back to the land but more
importantly it's a planning and every
time you cut it it's like it says Whoopi
I can grow again and it's got a root
system that allows it to grow up again
and you can you can produce enormous
amounts of nitrogen rich biomass that
either get plugged back in or that you
feed to in an animal and return the
animal waste back the other thing that
happens with forage legumes is that
you're not plowing in because they have
to be there there you know prati also
takes longer to get them seated farmers
keep them in for two to four years and
so you're naphthalene those fields
annually so there's an opportunity to
quickly increase soil organic matter
because these crops were made in place
they reduce the amount of plowing and
they ameliorate or they repair the
damage that's been caused by plowing and
at the same time they supply nitrogen
bring props and to animals that you feed
that forged so red clover is like the
magic bullet for farmers in western
humor and it was primarily red clover
and Timothy some farmers were using
names in the 18th century when it was
not common by 1839 New York led the
nation in the production of head and
Bidwell another agricultural historian
says that in will be growing region of
the western part of the state and was
talking about the north if it'd been
found that the growing of clover and the
raising of cattle and sheep on the
depleted peatlands would greatly
increase their yields and of course the
reason that that's happening is because
it's restoring soil again so it takes
forged legumes along with the tight
integration of animals and crops like
cloud-based agricultural systems in
western New York both productive and
sustainable so here are the conclusions
that after that I withdraw from its
first at airport maze was highly
productive and sustainable because first
they were firing on these very fertile
alpha songs with high levels of slow
the absence of plows far from being a
disadvantage was the reason that they
were able to maintain their soil organic
matter because they weren't oxidizing
with intensive cultivation New York
farmers on the other hand didn't have a
chance of maintaining those wheels they
likely got the permit in the first 1802
1840 likely yields at least in the early
eighteen hundreds were quite reasonable
when they moved on to those alpha cells
but certainly by 1845 indication was
that the yields were there may shields
were not good at and that was caused by
the reduction of soil organic matter
that was a result of tillage the lack of
appropriate management practices
including forages manure and rotations
was also a part of this and of course
solving that problem required the
introduction of forage language so I and
there
yes yes so how did the iroquois the
native peoples maintain their soil
organic matter they must have done
something to get the corn into the
ground as they must also have taken off
that yield because that's what the what
the generalist oldest thing they've got
a lot of maize off there so why is the
soil organic matter not being because
the most philosophy organic matter comes
from tillage not from crop removal so as
long as that soil organic matter stays
at four percent which there's no reason
to think that it won't right if you're
not plowing up a whole field there's no
reason to think that it won't stay at
four percent and in fact you're adding
crop residues back to that mound weeds
corn stalks are all going back in
there's no reason to think that soil
organic matter levels are going to
decline the major loss of soil organic
matter at these young love comes from
clown tillage not soil right so as long
as soil organic matter levels stay at
four percent the soil can continue to
release so it's not the crop that's
taking out all that nitrogen it's the
flower if you look at how much nitrogen
is in a 75 bushel acre yield of corn it
somewheres between 75 and maybe 125
pounds per acre of nitrogen you've got
more than enough in the soil
to do that I understand that some of it
is getting oxidized but you're only
doing a small amount and you're
replacing lots of crop residues back in
that mouth so my my argument is that the
soil organic matter could be stable and
that's what it counts for the
sustainability some they didn't spend
all their time weaving because they
didn't have the same weeks almost all of
our nasty weeds came from here so good
at the worst you guys know it's the
truth if you look at the worst weeds in
new European airports and they weren't
plowing why do you think we have so many
we found because we plow and we create
ideal conditions for weeks to Germany
right so without plowing they weren't
doing that they were not spreading wings
through animal which is the way most of
the weeds got spread from Europe right
came either with other stuff eaten by
animals spread hither and yon through
animal waste right none of those things
were happening so they were pretty damn
low anything sets you take 80 100 pounds
per acre of nitrogen home each crop in
just indicated how much what is the pool
of nitrogen that's in that until soil in
turn with the same how many hundred palm
spring well basically if you if you if
you believe you know radiant and while
they say I think that you for every
percent of soil organic matter you can
get 22
pounds oxidized per year released for
you okay so if you've got four percent
soil organic matter you've got somewhere
between 80 and 160 pounds well that's
not even as much as you know you already
took up 75 to 100 right and you have
additional coming from precipitation and
decomposition right so you can plan on
another 15 to 30 annual contribution
from precipitation and decomposition for
plant residues that's just crop residues
if you don't tell harder you're going to
lose no sir no no not true at all they
plant residues do not volatilize the
decomposition will will take place
whether it's whether it's it's covered
with with soil org or not that is not
going to it's not good at all
so I mean the real question is is the
soil organic matter of levels did they
remain state there is no indication that
Iroquois were practicing shifting
cultivation no indication at all they
were in the same fields continues there
were lots of indications that they were
burning right and they did sometimes
change fields but they were not rotating
field cutting burning resting and
returning to the same field and I mean
you could argue that they had plenty of
soil they no need to return to the same
field so there could be an argument that
yes they were cutting inverting they
were going to new fields but the
indication is now there's very little
evidence in the historical documents
that they were routinely opening new
fields particularly because of soil
depletion no indication of that at all
lots of indication of that in New
England along the eastern seaboard
Virginia North South Carolina and
Georgia lots of indication that that's
what farmers there were doing because
they were really having problems because
they had these articles or spoto songs
or Incept assaults that have much lower
amounts of organic oh we've got some
questions over 90 bucks sorry forgot you
were here far away all right James one
during the last couple of decades we've
seen quite a bit of attention to reduced
tillage in this very same region and I
was wondering if you have any
observations on how that is being done
if it's being done in a way that
increases the odds of recovering the
productivity I mean I think that any
attempts to decrease tillage are
be helpful for long-term you know
productivity of silence I but I think it
also means that you have to look at how
do you get that organic band back in not
just that you stop doing that that you
begin to use other practices whether
their cover crops or animal manure
things that will increase soil organic
matter I know when I've spoken with
queering kettering of about corn yields
she says that she can predict a corneal
based on this organic matter content
almost depending on where it comes from
right but at any time that they have
soil organic matter levels that are
between three and four percent it's very
hard for them to get a higher yield
regardless of how much intergen and
fertilizers they add so certainly soil
organic matter i think is being
increasingly recognized as the key to
productivity and in general it's hard to
increase soil or yak better just by
adding nitrogen you have to have other
practices in place that that you know
allow for that to happen
Shane do we have any information on
rainfall or rainfall patterns over that
that period of time that could have been
besides the organic soil organic matter
that there could be some of their
offsetting that made plant growth for
more luxurious during that era know when
there's even some indications that there
were several periods in which
temperatures were quite a bit cooler
which would actually cost quite a bit of
difficulty with corn grow and some
indications that in some years things
did not go well so that yields you know
inclined to be because of your climate
weather and about precipitation I I
don't have any information at all but I
can't I mean most of the time in New
York we don't sell terribly from
precipitation in a deficit we do get the
occasional drug abuse but I would
suspect that they would be relatively
similar with the ups and downs that
would still see
what would happen if superimposes
instead of continuous corn the three
sisters program on these soils would it
decrease the pressure on soil organic
matter and nitrogen or would it blow I
mean a lot of the results i showed you
actually were somewhere from foreign
monoculture and some of those cordials
were from three sisters were from poly
cultures what we found was that there
was no difference in coordinates whether
they were grown as monocultures or as
three sisters so my observation is that
in terms of nitrogen the beans would
provide almost nothing because they're
being eaten there is some in the stems
and leaves over a long term your kind of
addict to the pool that you know soil
soil nitrogen pools is getting attitude
but in the short term now that much the
quantity it's hard to you know makin any
estimates what we found was that
although corn yields were not affected
by whether they were grown as as
monocultures or poly cultures that beans
and pumpkin were great with effect in
other words you took a tremendous drop
and yields if you were if you compared
along be monoculture to being grown as
part of the three sisters there's also
evidence that the Iroquois grew beans by
themselves and pumpkins by themselves
they didn't always grow them mixed in so
they were clearly you know kind of
deciding whether they needed to add to
the stores of beans they probably didn't
plant them with
we're looking maybe to trade or
something like that they probably put in
in you know monocultures of those and
how much that might have impacted I mean
there's not a lot of crop residue from
proteins and not a whole lot from
pumpkin even or squash you can get
fairly substantial amounts of crop
residue for particularly good crop so I
would think that the major of that comes
I've seen pictures especially from
elementary school days of black and
white line drawings of presumably
coastal Native Americans showing
settlers how to fertilize their corn by
with an Asian fish and now is that
revisionist history completely bogus or
what's the matter it seems to be some
combination there's been a huge argument
going on for about 50 years about how
true that is my sense is that it may
have been true for coastal Indians they
were growing on his boat assaults and
I'm really poor nutrient status you know
soils and it would have made sense for
them to do that they were also growing
much smaller areas there's no indication
of 100 200 acre
fields of corn out in New England right
at the time of contact whereas Iroquois
are going on some of the finest oils we
have in the country at model Souls but
they're pretty pretty darn good and
they're growing these huge acreages so I
mean how the rule do you gather up all
these fish and other be ready to each
Mary picnic it's a it kind of it doesn't
seem realism so and it doesn't match
with kind of what we know about the
soils it's a lot of work to do for no
response I throw the vision and nothing
happens you still get the same grade you
yes how good an estimate of the total
area in cultivation at this time was and
how they ask we have the population some
excellent questions likely to be quite
small because the total population was
probably quite small populations were
going up and down because of disease
because of warfare so the iroquois
populations were probably never much
higher than forty to fifty thousand and
so when we looked at at what the area is
that i mean if you look at village sites
and look at the areas of good land you
know round those village sites if you go
out to the Genesee in that area if you
look up at gun and again and look at the
highest yielding soils it's way more
than what they could possibly be the
last night so they as the types of land
pressure that were you know you know
evident in in other areas and so that
so they were not using nearly this the
land that they add to the capacity that
it could have no could have been done so
certainly a small population on good
soils and napping push to use the
resource to expose
sort of related to that how large was
the community that might be associated
with hundred acres of anywheres from a
couple hundred to a cup of fasting and
we don't know what that 200 acres of
corn was the only field that was had by
a you know particular community if they
had a couple but generally Iroquois and
villages tended to be a couple of
hundred up to as many as 2,000 so up in
genesee into Tennessee Geneva there's a
Seneca community about 1720 that may
have been around 1500 people so not huge
you know areas but then again you know
now in significant or not huge
population there's a whole lot more work
that could be done matching kind of
soils and end populations were beginning
to get some good estimates on natural
population numbers a number of Iroquois
studies scholars who are
beyond that actually tools and records
so very interested in population numbers
and how they're going up and down I just
have to persuade them that it's
worthwhile to look at the soils
potentially interesting thank this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu